Hello Freak bitches.
But I think the media is slowly but surely becoming irrelevant and that the real
meat,
the real media is what's,
you know,
look,
the only reason why the news let's,
we don't even have to name an organization,
but in,
in quotes,
the news is the news is because they have a long history of disseminating
information,
right?
But people,
regular people are doing that.
Now.
A lot of people are doing that now through different websites and youtube
channels.
And I think that that's the future.
And it,
we don't have to be,
as long as you're honest and you have a,
a real objective point of view,
you don't have to be sanctioned by some gigantic corporation to get the fucking
truth.
Now.
No.
In fact,
you,
you're less likely to get the truth out because of your sponsors.
Because I mean,
MSNBC is owned by Ge,
MSNBC as the quote unquote liberal network and they're owned by like a company
that like fucking could profit off of war.
Dave Ruben had a post that he did today to have go to Dave Rubin's Twitter page
about why people distrust the media and why the media has garbage today in their
coverage of this Kevin Spacey thing.
Because all of these different outlets were saying that Kevin Spacey came out as
gay.
That was the name,
the main headlines.
Kevin.
Yes.
Kevin Spacey came out as gay.
This was like,
well,
let's have a push it up.
Pull it up.
Yeah,
that sounds like we should be applauding.
Well,
this is,
but this is,
it just shows you what it is.
Like,
look at this media.
Why scroll up.
Why doesn't the public trust us?
Because this,
I look at this actor Kevin Spacey Decides,
uh,
declares he lives as a gay man.
Kevin Spacey announced Sunday night that he will live as a gay man.
I mean,
look at all these different than New York Daily News.
Reuters,
the daily beast.
They're saying that he's gay,
but they're saying he's gay.
Because a kid came out where a man now came out and said,
Kevin tried to fuck.
And when he was 14 she,
so this is like saying that he declares he lives life as a gay man.
God Damn it.
That's not the store.
No,
that sounds like a festive thing.
We should all be like congratulations to Kevin Spacey.
Not only that he said this in this statement where he was apologizing for this
thing.
So like this,
this is so crazy when also that's how they choose.
But they choose to frame it that way because someone coming out is going to get
a lot of people paying attention.
Right.
Well and also I don't the the link to link pedophilia always to homosexuality is
isn't true.
Like there are a lot of of people who would consider themselves a heterosexual,
whether it was in the church or whatever who are raping kids cause it's,
it's a power thing and they're sick or pedophilia is just different.
Being attracted to kids is different than being attracted to like,
like men.
And this is like also really dangerous for to equate like uh,
trying to fuck a 14 year old with just like going down to west Hollywood to like
do some gay shit.
Well,
I,
he has admitted that he did it and he said he doesn't recall it at all.
But he did say that he had a problem with drinking and you know,
if he did do anything,
he was very sorry.
And we're talking about something that happened at least 30 years ago.
Right.
So here's also a problem and this is,
this needs to be addressed because we really don't know whether or not this
guy's memory is accurate because something 30 years ago,
the problem with being 14 years old,
his first of all,
14 years old,
you're so God damn confused.
I don't remember shit.
He don't remember shit.
You are a wash in hormones and confusion and insecurity.
And
he might've had five years of my life too.
He,
yeah,
he might've had some weird run in with Kevin Spacey that may or may not have
been sexually predatory.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened.
Right.
But two to decide that he's absolutely telling the truth and Kevin Spacey's
absolutely covering this up by coming out as gay to using that sort of diffuse
the situation.
This is sort of the,
this is almost the opposite of when Twitter declares you guilty.
This is like the news declaring you almost like innocent,
right?
Where I don't know what happened to letting,
uh,
courts decide and talk about people being accused and whatnot where Twitter can
just like be like if,
if they say you're done,
like,
uh,
you had Jon Ronson on,
right?
Yes.
Did he talk,
did he read that publicly shamed?
So good.
Yeah,
it's really good.
And it's just like,
man,
these people's lives are done.
And I was part of all that shit.
I,
I tweeted about fucking Justine sacco.
Yep.
Straight up.
I did.
And I read that book and it's like,
yeah,
you don't,
you don't think of that.
You know what I mean?
It's a free shot.
I mean,
that's,
look,
the worst example of that is people that are completely anonymous,
right?
You weren't completely anonymous,
which is why you face the blow back.
But there's a lot of people that had just have a Twitter egg and they,
I mean,
they're completely anonymous.
They have a bunch of random letters and numbers is a name and they fucking
attacked people left and right.
Yeah.
It's a common thing on Twitter.
I mean,
we're seeing a new kind of interaction with human beings.
Yeah.